CED out 90s action movies are back in
2024 baby let's
[Music]
go and for the YouTube sensor algorithm
robot I was talking about Coca-Cola what
do you think I was talking about so
beekeeper Stars Jason Stam which means
you know exactly what this movie is
going to be he's pretty reliable in that
sense it's like when you see Liam NES in
a movie trailer and he's like honey
how's it going Happy Thanksgiving you're
like oh okay so that's the family that's
going to die so we can go on his Rampage
same thing when you see Jason STM in
here and he's like yeah I'm a beekeeper
I'll keep bees you know that's just a
strange way for him to say military
Special Ops professional killer type is
going to lay down some bodies and after
his nice old landlord is robbed and then
dead yeah that's exactly what he does
your enjoyment or lack of enjoyment in
this movie is going to depend on what
you want and what you accept the movie
as being movie is directed by David a
director of Fury and Suicide Squad not
that the suicide squad remakable
nonsense no we're talking the real deal
I will say this the first 30 minutes or
so of this movie was awesome we're not
talking cheesy 9s action movie fun
awesome I'm talking it was actually
pretty sweet I mean the villains the
scumbags the baddies they seemed a
little cartoony but for the most part
it's this sweet nice old lady who gets
scammed with the one one of those online
popups and she calls she's like oh it
looks like I have a virus can you help
me here's my IP address that's real [__]
that's out there my mom almost got hit
with one of those things it's no joke
don't [__] with the elderly that's the
lesson here now first building he takes
out I'm just saying it was satisfying I
mean if you're not at all a '90s action
movie fan we'll pass this one by there's
going to be nothing here for you no
judgment I'm just saying it as a fact
it's like if I'm talking about a beach
talking about how oh that beach was a
lot of fun Anakin Skywalker watching the
video I should say if you don't like
sand you probably won't like it though
not everything's for everyone but when
it had focus when it was clear it was
trying to be this celebration of '90s
action movies that's when the movie was
actually in its Zone the action
sequences were enjoyable some of the
kills some of the hits were really
bloody and satisfying that said in the
second half of the movie we'll say the
last Act of the movie or so it starts to
take itself too seriously to the point
where the cheese doesn't feel like a
celebration anymore the cheese starts to
feel bad maybe it's the stick that was
wearing off maybe it's the fact that the
movie was taking itself too seriously by
the end point is it didn't mesh as well
as it did in the first half I mean The
Beekeeper thing is ridiculous but it was
fun ridiculous at first and the be puns
there's so many be puns in this movie
The be puns in beekeeper are comparable
to the ice cold and freezing puns in
Batman and Robin it's funny at first
then just gets out of control but that
is the decade they're pulling from I
think but it's when people start talking
about him and they're like look we have
to deal with The Beekeeper you don't
understand he's a beekeeper I just
couldn't take it as seriously as I felt
like the movie wanted me to take it it's
like when people argue about
friendsgiving it's like I I want to take
it as seriously as you want me to take
it but I just can't because you're
saying it that way low key has a really
solid cast Jeremy Irons is in the movie
Josh Hutcherson I thought was great as
what was his name Hunter this movie is
so Dollar Store John Wick you know it
it's just you can see the makeup in here
you can see the DNA of it the quiet
retired professional killer type some
rich [__] causes death in his life
that brings him out of retirement now
he's going after that Young Rich
[__] the Young Rich Punk's Father
Figure who's in the know who knows the
kind of damage this assassin coming out
of retirement is going to bring down on
them there's even this super secret
underground call center you can tell
someone was like okay John Wick but hear
me out on this a beekeeper but unlike
John Wick will'll have these stretches
particularly in the second half where
the action slows down concentrate on
these two FBI people that I personally
didn't give a [__] about I should have
because one of them is the daughter of
the old lady who died I feel like there
should be more care there but I just
didn't care also their Dynamic was weird
he was like oh hey you like fires your
mom's old house it's burning down let's
go I was like I her mom who died
yesterday you want to deliver that with
some gloves on there buddy holy [__]
yeah in the
end it's a Jason STM action movie that
totally throws back to cheesy 9s action
movies cheesy 9s action movies it's not
a smooth ride some of the dialogue is
just laughable like laughing at the
movie not with the movie but there are
more than a few scenes in which you're
laughing with the movie because the
movie knows what it is and it leans into
it sometimes it leans a little too far
sometimes it pulls back on the lean
takes itself a little too seriously it's
a little inconsistent in that sense it
doesn't keep in what we call the
goldilock Zone the whole time if you and
your friends love those cheesy 99s
action movies this could be a fun movie
to add to that collection add to that
binge night bring the friends bring the
alcohol fun time if you're drunk yeah
now it's a party all right so the
beekeeper have you seen it what did you
think about it or what's your favorite
'90s throwback action movie not from the
9s feel like I asked you that recently
well I haven't asked you that in 2024
let this be the first time whatever it
is whatever you think comment below let
me know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see
more
[Music]